you guys seen his guitar Mason Ramsey if
you look at like his album cover his
guitar is like that's his guitar on his
body it's so cute
hey miss Mason Ramsey and welcome to
Jiki these are my 10 essentials that's
gonna get cut out I just know it
what's up GQ my name is Phineas and
these are my essentials so the first
essential I wanted to bring was my
laptop which I have this GQ sticker on
cuz I'm a big fan of GQ to produce a
song I think a lot of people think you
need a lot of gear and I don't know for
me like I just need a laptop that's
pretty much it there's a couple songs on
the last EP of mine a couple songs I've
done for other artists that I've
literally like priests on flights using
the actual keys of the laptop to like
play chords and then orchestrating
everything else and all I need is a
laptop to produce a song this is my
Apple watch this was like a compulsive
retail therapy by a couple years ago for
me and when I got it I was like why did
I get this and then I just sort of wore
it every day for a couple months and now
like when I forget to wear it looked
down at my like bare wrist all the time
this also has a really great microphone
and you can like record low like voice
memos straight into here she's pretty
awesome but the the best feature of this
is that you can ring your phone from it
and I lose my phone four to five
thousand times a day so it's pretty
awesome just feel like where's my phone
and then you know where it is this band
is from a website called case 2phi this
was a present from my my girlfriend this
much classier than the the fake Gucci
one that I had before this I pretty much
like exclusively drink like iced coffee
drinks it has to be like an Arctic
tundra to to justify like a hot coffee
for me it could be like you know
Christmas even and raining and I'll be
like gotta get an iced coffee I'll be
wearing like an overcoat and like
shivering and just
my like iced americano what's that and I
get to chew the ice it's a bonus but I
think I think mainly my relationship
with coffee is just how much caffeine I
can have in my body for the duration of
the day to offset whatever small amount
of sleep I got that night so this is my
phone and I keep my phone in the a folio
case like a wallet case I do that
because I up until like earlier this
year I was like a three pocket person
which I think a lot of guys are or I'd
have my phone in one pocket my keys in
the other pocket and my wallet the other
pocket I just got kind of like exhausted
of that and having bulgy pockets and one
of the things I did was I installed nest
locks on my house which are like little
code locks gonna lock with your phone so
I got rid of my house key I got a car
and this is the key to my car and then I
got rid of my wallet and just put my my
money's in here this is all I all I
travel with part of the reason for that
is that when I tour I would leave my car
keys at home anyway because I'd be away
from my car in my house for you know
five weeks at a time and so I would get
back to LA and I would have to like
reincorporate like having my car keys on
me at all times into my like like what I
was remembering and I would like leave
my keys everywhere so I just condensed
it to like this all the time and it's
purple because I thought I was ordering
a black one and I ordered a purple one
and I'm appropriating um single mothers
over 40 culture that's what I'm doing
with this purple case this is a trimmer
from a website called manscaped it uh
it's for your balls it doesn't it
doesn't chop your balls when you use it
it's pretty great yeah I keep my ball
trimmer in my face trimmer separate
trimmers just out of respect for both
areas you know I have a face trimmer
also that has like a nose hair trimmer
attachment that's pretty exciting to me
I got really serious about trimming my
nose hairs when one time my girlfriend
and I were you know face to face as you
often are with your loved one and she
tucked one of my nose hairs back up into
my nostril so I was like he time to
really double down on this nose hair
trimming [ __ ] because that's never gonna
happen I guess
shave the neckline you know it's really
funny to me when some guys do like the
chin the chin strap or they just shave
all this stuff that's so horrible
looking anybody in this room these are
my favorite pair of headphones ever
they're called a th m50x they're a pair
of Audio Technica headphones and for me
like basically up until I had these
headphones like it's really hard to like
mix music on headphones because a lot of
like the music that I'm producing is
very like sub heavy like it's a lot of
like music that you feel in your chest
it's really hard to replicate that with
like really tiny speakers over your ears
and these have just such a good bass
response that like for all of blood
harmony and a lot of when we all fall
asleep where do we go
this was like my primary source of like
reference mixing headphones so these are
like a huge deal to me this is the thing
I'm the most excited about talking about
this is my skincare regimen a couple
months ago I had like just a the worst
breakout I've ever had I've struggled
with like acne since I was like 14 I've
been to like 10 to 15 dermatologists
over the course of that eight years it
was a really punishing a demoralizing
experience and at 22 I suddenly had like
the worst breakout of my life while we
were on tour
Billy's album was coming out my skin was
just like exploding this was my face
like a couple months ago it's pretty
unpleasant there's not so many pimples
anymore and the reason that is is
because of all this stuff it's it's his
woman named Biba who has a company and
she's a facialist and I go get facials
from her and then her line is so great I
use this acne wash every day and then
this toner and then I use this medicine
serum it's like a vitamin C based serum
there's like a sunscreen that I use also
sunscreen and moisturizer like a big
deal and then every night I'll use this
cleanser and then this toner and then
I'll use this acne gel and it changed my
life
this is a guitar that I got while we
were on tour this past summer I was in
Boston and a day off I was like ooh I
really want to go get a good tomorrow
and I'm in a really fortunate position
where I have a relationship with Fender
or they make guitars for me and send
them to me so I very rarely have to
actually go buy a guitar anymore she's
really awesome but that one day I was
like oh I want to go get a guitar today
I bought one in a while and the last
time I bought a guitar was when I was
like pretty flat broke and my teens I
couldn't afford a nice guitar at all the
only place that was open at like 7:30
p.m. was at Guitar Center that was like
across the street from Berklee College
of Music so I walked in and every kid in
there is like a Berkley undergrad that
was just like look I just shredding on
their guitars and it was very
intimidating to me because I can play a
really sick open G chord that's my
knowledge of guitar and I walked around
the store and I found this disney/pixar
cordova sponsored guitar basically made
of balsa wood it's made of the same
stuff that like a paper airplane that's
made out of it's incredibly light it's
super small and the guy selling it to me
gave me a look like this that was the
look that he gave me as he sold me this
guitar and as I was leaving I was like
oh I'd love to buy a case for it you
guys have a case for that guitar and he
was like no it plays beautifully and
then I had it with me every day for the
rest of the tour and I wrote I don't
miss you at all on this guitar and I
wrote partners in crime on this guitar
and it's small enough that it's not in
anyone's way if I'm sitting like on a
bench seat in a tour bus next to people
a lot of time you are and if I was like
Lil Hank Williams the guitar that's like
six times bigger than my body wouldn't
work
this is like the only like bigger
essential I have and this is a a pelican
that I got outfitted that I take
everywhere that has all my recording
gear I'll show you guys what I mean this
is an Apollo Aero that's what I use to
plug my mics in is my Norman TLM 103
screws on like that there's the cable
goes from here here this is my version
of a makeup tutorial
now that might have seemed like a lot of
work to demonstrate something but in
terms of like actually recording a song
that's pretty fast and then I'll hold it
like this
I'll wear those headphones I was just
bragging about and this is how I
recorded like everything on my EP it's
how Billy and I just recorded her new
song it's it's pretty great I'm a big
fan of like holding this in your hands
because like when you're standing in a
mic stand for some reason like you plant
your feet you get in a good location and
you're kind of like this far away from
it the whole time whether you're seeing
really loud you're singing really quiet
and I like it being handheld because I
think just you're kind of like motion
response to it means that when you're
singing really quietly you'll hold it
really close to your face like this when
you start shouting you automatically
kind of hold it further away and I think
it just kind of is like the dynamics of
it are much much tighter automatically
through that so this has been my like
refined way of recording in every hotel
room I'm a big fan so I wanted to save
the only real essential that I actually
brought today like the only thing that
truly is like essential to my life for
for laughs but it's definitely the first
one that I thought of and
is this Claudia this is my girlfriend
thanks so much for being here I was like
hey would you come be my like my
essential and the 10 essentials thing
and I think she didn't understand that I
wanted her to like she's the most
important part of my life easily and I
think at first she thought I was just
like would you come watch me film my 10
essentials videos she would watch a lot
of things that she do I was like yeah I
if you feel that I really should be
there I can come and support you last
thing I want to do is like objectify my
girlfriend she's her own person
and I think much more valuable than me
or than my iced coffee or my beep of
beauty supply products but the feeling
is mutual
yeah if I became a man and filmed 10
essentials you would also be in my 10
essentials Klein I've been dating for
like a little over a year and one of the
things that we get to do a lot like to
her a lot is get to travel together a
lot if I'm on a flight without her I go
through like several movies and like I
don't know like all this nonsense and
I'm uncomfortable the whole time and I'm
just waiting to get like Wi-Fi so I
could text her again and if Claudia is
on the flight with me then we just like
make each other laugh for like five or
six hours we're a very low stress couple
it's pretty awesome you know
yeah you're the best we've really locked
down traveling we make the most of every
delay I would categorize travel as like
a stressful experience and with you I've
never stressed and by yeah it's pretty
good we're already where we want to be a
car that's perfect I know we're the
worst up once again my name is Phineas
thank you guys so much for watching my
ten essentials
[Laughter]
[Music]